All right.
So here we are back at our eye again and
let's start talking about sort
of the most important part.
This is the part of your eye,
the retina.
It's the part of your
brain that is in your eye.
Now here is a picture
schematic of a retina, okay?
And first you'll notice there are these
receptors called rods and cones, and
we'll talk about those in a minute.
And then those receptors
connect to these things called
horizontal bipolar cells, which take
the chemical output of the receptors and
eventually turn them into stimulation
for these ganglion cells,
which are the first proper nerves, these
are the nerves that actually produce
firing spikes that we're used to for
nerve cells.
But when you look at this,
you should look at that curvature, and
it should bother you a little bit,
right?
So here's the picture of my eye, okay.
But you see of course my thing is,
is bent this way.
And this thing is sort of bent that way.
So actually what I need to do is, and
I'm really proud of this,
is we need to rotate that picture.
So this curvature here is
like this curvature there.
At which point you realize what
comes up this way, the light.
All right?
The human system has what's referred
to as an inverted retina, okay?
And that is the light comes in,
and passes through, all this gunk.
It passes through,
there are blood vessels in here,
there's nerves,
it passes right through them.
Then it hits your photo receptors, okay,
and then any stray light keeps going,
sort of gets absorbed.
This background layer,
this is called the pigment epithelium.
This is actually a very black
pigment in the back of your eye.
So, you might ask,
why would you build an inverted retina?
>> Why would you build
an inverted retina?
>> Nobody asked me, but
here's some, some speculation.
There are a couple of things.
The, the reason that,
that I like best is.
What happens is, is that the light goes
through here and anyone that happens to
hit the photoreceptors,
right there, gets absorbed.
And then after that,
it hits this pigment epithelium.
Okay, and what that means is
the pigment epithelium absorbs
any stray light, so it eliminates
scatter within the, within the eye.
And that gives you
a very sharp resolution.
It reduces your ability to
see at night a little bit.
We'll talk about the sensitivity
of rods and cones in a little bit.
But it gives you this, this idea
that you know, first the, the light,
whatever light gets absorbed by
the detectors goes into processing and
everything else is absorbed and removed.
It doesn't cause any disturbance.
It does mean that there's a funny
sort of thing that goes on.
These structures produce a very, they're
clear because they're made out of you
know, gelatinous stuff
that is biological tissue.
But of course it causes little shadows,
right.
So if you go right
past the blood vessel,
it'd be actually a little
bit of a shadow.
So you might ask,
why don't we see these shadows.
>> Why don't we see these shadows?
>> The human eyeball is remarkable.
Anything that's perfectly stabilized
on your eye, the brain just removes.
Okay?
So
that shadow stays exactly in
the same place on the retina.
The brain just removes it.
In fact, there are some cool tricks
you can do by building little sta,
stabilization systems that will keep
something projected exactly the same
place on the eye and
eventually you just don't see it.
So, anyway, so
that's the inverted retina of the eye